movies based on true stories often take
considerable creative license but one
specific choice to shuffle the facts in
Gran Turismo has some critics waving red
flags the Gran Turismo video games don't
have much of a story to adapt to a
feature-length film so Sony's new movie
of the same name draws from real life
experiences the story of yan
martinborough draws from the Racer's
actual Journey from religiously playing
the Gran Turismo games to taking his
skills to the racetrack as with many
biopics some details are accurate While
others are fictionalized or exaggerated
to create a more compelling narrative
and one moment in Gran Turismo may have
some viewers wondering what the real
story is during one of the movie's
pivotal races Yan attempts to get ahead
of the competition but in the process he
loses control of his vehicle which
careens into a crowd of Spectators Yan
is told it was a freak accident and
wasn't his fault but in the hospital
it's revealed the Collision resulted in
a person's death it serves as the lowest
point of the character's journey and he
questions whether he wants to continue
racing that accident actually did happen
in 2015 at the Nurburgring Nissan the
team for which martinborough drove
issued a statement following the
incident that read in part several
Spectators were injured in the incident
and despite immediate efforts one of
them succumbed to their injuries the
others have been taken immediately to
hospital for care in the movie trainer
Jack Salter pushes Yan to get back
behind the wheel in time for the 24
Hours of Le Mans to prove he has what it
takes to race alongside the best
most people can't
I got a feeling you're not most people
through sheer determination and will Yan
manages to place third he overcomes
adversity and kicks off an incredible
racing career the only problem is that
things didn't happen in that order in
real life Martin burrough's accident
took place in 2015 the 24 Hours of Le
Mans race where Yan triumphantly came in
third occurred in 2013 a full two years
before the crash the movie Alters the
timeline of events so that Yan could
have his lowest moment come before he
took the podium the movie version of yan
is directly impacted by the accident
during the 24 Hours of Le Mans he
Witnesses another racer crash and this
impedes his performance until he can
shake out of it it Paints the two events
as connected when in real life they
didn't really have anything to do with
one another it's normal for biopics to
alter events to construct a more
compelling story that better aligns with
dramatic character arcs but plenty of
critics have taken the film to task for
changing details about a moment that
resulted in a real person losing their
life the movie's already facing an
uphill battle from reviewers for a form
formulaic story and some have directly
addressed how the timeline change comes
across as insensitive Ali Welsh wrote
for polygon while the crash did happen
pretty much as depicted Jason Hall and
Zach Balon screenplay time shifts it in
order to Stage it as a defining
motivating setback on martinborough's
hero's journey to his Le Mans Podium the
actual accident happened years later
arguably a tasteless reframing of a
fatal event others have mentioned how it
seems crass to frame a person's death as
being integral to martinborough's
Journey when it didn't really help him
at Le Mans in an interview with
driving.co.uk martinborough discussed
the importance of including the accident
in the film saying I feel it would have
been a disservice for the audience for
that not to be in there he didn't
mention altering the timeline so
audiences can decide whether it feels
tasteless or not when Gran Turismo gets
a limited release on August 11th before
opening wide on August 25th
[Music]
foreign